a gleam that gleam of hope I think he is
a generational change agent five eager
everyone's ready for a change so I think
he has the best chance to change the way
politics is done in this country we've
had in a generation because he speaks of
change even though he doesn't speak of
how to change what do you think when
people say that that the Obama campaign
and the campaign rhetoric are mostly
platitudes about change and there's no
substance how do you respond to the
right well there you can actually go to
Barack Obama calm / issues and and the
question really is that I meet a lot of
people and they have a clue what Obama
stands for and they're all voting form
why do you think that is right some of
those people do know and just don't
focus on it and I do think it's
interesting that the campaign has
decided in their rhetoric not to focus
on that not that they haven't thought
through the policy proposals but that it
isn't the public face of the campaign
the same way it is for some of the other
candidates
and I have to assume that that's a
calculation in their part that
ultimately the people that care about it
will go and look it up and the people
that don't care about it you know
they're looking for something else you
do you feel like you're getting swept up
in a big movement when you're voting for
Barack Obama yes I do i do I think
Barack has the ability to mobilize and I
think that's what is getting my
generation out to vote in record numbers
and I like to see that in the cancer I
haven't seen you in my voting years the
engagement of our youth most people
aren't looking for you know a health
care plan with one you know specific
versus another they're looking for so
why is Barack Obama making me go that
extra step and go online and find out
what changed means what about lazy
people like me who are lazy thinkers and
lazy when it comes to politics well I
don't think you're lazy I am the most
certainly way okay
it's you know i'm i'm sure it's a
decision they made at the campaign it's
certainly not that he doesn't understand
the policy or not that they haven't
thought through the policy implications
i think what they're offering is just
it's not just policy it's something more
as well
then I've to the wolf and it's dangerous
this ron paul is in your estimation a
dangerous wolf attendance wolf I'm glad
that the dangerous wolf Mitt Romney's
gone it was also a dangerous move was
very dangerous